hey guys it's Jonah here the key to
losing weight isn't just watching what's
on your plate it is also watching what's
in your glass so if you have been
between your regular workouts eating
well but the weight isn't shifting
well sometimes it can be done to not be
aware about your daily beverages
drinking soft drinks energy drinks
packet fruit juices health drinks fancy
coffee or tea loaded with sugar or
artificial sweeteners can sabotage your
weight loss goals not drinking enough
water every day can slow down weight
loss our body needs enemies 2.5 to 3
liters of water every day
water is essential to filter waste
products and toxins from our body so
that it can function at its best so I'm
gonna share with you 5 nutritious drinks
which you can drink on a daily basis and
it can speed up your windows goal if you
have been watching my videos I've
recommended green teeth over and over
again as a great natural fat burner this
is because green tea is rich in
antioxidants which aid in burning fat
especially belly fat by triggering the
release of fat from fat cells so if your
goal is to lose belly fat then consume
green tea as part of your daily
beverages consumed between 3 to 5 cups a
day for best results you can also watch
my green tea video here to learn more
about the other amazing benefits to your
body at the unsweetened tea which can
aid with weight loss include peppermint
tea oolong tea party or white tea so
whey protein isn't just for men or body
builders in fact if combined with
regular exercisers whey protein can
speed up weight loss while maintaining
and building lean muscles protein is a
much more satisfying you too
in comparison to fat cops what this
means is that by drinking whey protein
it will help to keep you satisfied for
much longer
hence eating less throughout the day it
can also boost your metabolism
I'm sure for those of you who are
already drinking whey protein you will
agree with me that just one scoop will
keep you satisfied for at least two to
three hours use this way shake as a
small meal replacement so for instance I
will have my way protein as my
mid-morning snack prior to my work
gallon with this really cool Uemura one
shaker bottle I came across of this
bottle on Instagram and I just have to
share it with you guys so instead of
needing to carry extra containers for my
whey protein this lid has a supplement
container this water allows me to drink
my water separate from the supplement
and when I'm ready to have my supplement
all I have to do is push the button
shake and drink I mean how cool and
convenient is that so normal massive
bottle shakers or extra containers you
can check out the Instagram page and
also their website in the links below
and get your point shaker another way of
having whey protein is that you can
always add one scoop into your body
oatmeal muffins
thankee mixtures and more I'm sure we've
all read about the benefits of drinking
lemon water especially in the morning on
an empty stomach lemons are rich in
vitamin C and potassium which is a key
nutrient for healthy metabolism drinking
a one glass of lemon water in the
morning has been proven to improve
digestion
we hydrate the body when we gets up in
the morning our body is dehydrated from
not having any liquid for at least seven
to eight hours so we need to rehydrate
our body by drinking at least two to
three cups of water in the morning and
by just creasing two to three
tablespoons of lemon juice into your
water it can improve your digestion
reduce bloating release body toxins and
even boost your energy level drinking
lemon water can also help to reduce
wrinkles and lead to clearer skin so the
simple habit of drinking lemon juice
first thing in the morning and drink at
least three times a day can help to
support a healthy weight loss and I
would suggest trying these different
combinations for even more added
benefits lemon juice honey or maple
syrup with km pepper and 1 cup of water
lemon juice ginger juice honey and 1 cup
of water lemon juice honey episode a
vinegar and 1 cup of water lemon juice
honey and 1 cup of water or lemon juice
and 1 cup of tea you don't have to go on
any crazy lemon diet instead drinkable
water on a regular basis to support a
healthy weight loss regime I guess we
all would agree the best choice for
effective weight loss and to maintain a
healthy weight is to drink enough water
every day at least 2.5 to 3 liters of
water however water can be a boring
choice to some of you so let's make
naturally flavored water instead I'm
going to keep the recipe you really
simple so that you can make it under 5
minutes and you can keep trying
different
patience so the combination is simply to
use fruit or vegetable one or two
selections herbs or spices one selection
and one liter of water place all your
selected ingredients into a pitcher and
chill in the fridge for at least one
hour before serving if you like a
stronger flavor then place it overnight
and consumed within 24 hours here are a
few of my favorite combinations apple
and cinnamon cucumber lemon and fresh
mint leaves orange and vanilla cucumber
and lemongrass lemon orange and lime you
can add or reduce each ingredients
depending on how strong you want the
flavors to be this naturally flavored
drinks provide a subtle refreshing taste
to your palate without adding many
calories plus your body will benefit
from the fruits vegetables or herbs
infused water you can refill the water
one or two more times but the flavors
will know me as strong now if you were
to buy flavored water it could be added
with colors sugar and other unhealthy
agents so why would you do that make
your own flavored water instead and let
me know your favorite combination in the
comments below and finally coffee lover
you won't be happy to know that black
coffee made it into my list of top 5 and
nutritious drinks for weight loss black
coffee is calorie
and rich in antioxidants caffeine is
known to boost metabolism and suppress
hunger plus drinking a moderate amount
of coffee two to three cups a day can
also help to improve mood and
concentration so you're only cup of joe
isn't that bad after all but just the
caffeine with what goes into your coffee
I would either stick to that coffee or
just add a small amount of semi-skimmed
milk drinking fancy coffee with high
amount of food that milk sugar or syrup
on a regular basis can actually lead to
weight gain they tend to be high in
calories ranging from 150 calories and
even up to 400 calories depending on the
size and the other topics
just keep your coffee simple and basic
to gain its benefits these five
nutritious dreams are no more going up
drinks just drinking them on their own
without changing your lifestyle will not
help you lose weight so for instance by
drinking lemon water every day and
having your favorite jumps at the same
time would not help you lose weight
however if you eat a clean well-balanced
diet to your regular exercises and add
these drinks into your new lifestyle you
will see improvement on your weight and
overall health so make these drinks step
up picture and be sure to share it on
the pump hop app stay inspired stay
healthy and follow me as a chewiness so
if you do not yet have this fitness app
you have to download it and trust me it
will only help you towards a healthier
lifestyle link is in the description box
all the best for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
you
Oh